[Musik]
mein name ist abmarsch arbeit alles
gewohnte reiniger ich bin ja nicht buch
harry potter reiniger mit leib und seele
bin ich dabei mein name ist ingrid
buchholz ich bin seit acht jahren firma
clean servicepower tätig als
bereichsleiter als gebäude während man
glasreinigung fassadenreinigung grafite
der beim polieren reinigung und
schädlingsbekämpfung das sind so die
hauptthemen bei der gebäudereinigung
gibt es verschiedene aufgaben zum
beispiel die unterhaltsreinigung
reinigungskräfte putzen büros saugen
böden und machen die sanitäranlagen
sauber
die gebäudereiniger haben meist
speziellere aufgaben
sie reinigen glasfassaden entfernen
graffitis
und soll man teppiche sie benutzten
spezielle maschinen und reinigungsmittel
mehr über den beruf des gebäudereinigers
erfahrt ihr im nächsten teil
ich bin der grad das ist meine art dem
heute reinigen wir die bank dem material
aus wir haben heute den auftrag her bei
den bank wir haben den fassadenreinigung
auf position eins position zwei wir
haben eintracht entfernen position drei
wir haben deppisch polieren und position
4 wir haben blicken entfernt bei den
ponys oder nimmst du die erste position
derwisch flecken
dapd
ich mache mit alex die fassadenreinigung
und die graffiti entfernen weil es mich
dann legen wir los
mit dieser maschinen machen wir heute
die fassadenreinigung einmal die in
blauer kabel das zentralisierte wasser
kommt dahin hier ja oder sich schwarzer
kabel ist von jimmy da kommt da an die
zweite reihe
das wird so gebaut und nicht nur er muss
zur gedreht werden damit wir haben nicht
hin und her geht ja für den wasser
auflaufen lassen einmal mehr starten
würde ich durchdrehen und jetzt geht's
los
kurzum jaberg abkürzen
also immer wieder kurz vandalen die
hälfte der fenster gemacht einmal immer
größer machen halter unterbränd
einmal so ausmachen liegt noch darauf
dass die geräte aus
neid
auf dem hof
dann schön
auf die fassade
mai
du möchtest kannst du es ja auch mal
machen
die zwei varianten sind in china auf
schwamm das ein bisschen noch mit
leberkrebs so gar nicht denken
schwamm
mehr noch genau richtig so genau
ich versuch's mal kreisende bewegung
machen 53 sonderbewegungen kreisende
bewegungen sind besser das ist auch
schön in die poren eingibt du bist du
ist noch etwas
was ich noch mal ran bitten
die sowjets der arbeit schon lange
beendet wir sind fertig
so
wirklich rein damit so das ist das erste
treibt ist mir die maschine blue chips
kann man schon gesehen ein mal rein
ok so drehen jetzt fest ok habe ich mich
dann alles klar
dann kommt das ipad drauf zurück der ist
die folgen ist ja das müssen
anschließend das sagt das wasser rein
und die chemie später das ist das klare
wasser nach zum nachspülen haben so
ziehen das skript wir müssen also auch
anschließen
die einmal also das schmutzige wasser
später zu neutralisieren kommt dann hier
rein
so hießen wir das auch machen
da kommt das klare wasser rein so dann
kommt jetzt hier was dabei
jetzt haben wir geschrieben
der beschleuniger auch hier kommen wir
zum ihren das ist zentral für den vor
dem fleckchen ist zuviel staaten
immer kreise bewegung machen das doch
jede vor
mit chemie fühlst dann wenn man hier
ende fertig ist die bahn runter wo man
den weg sieht
sie laufen länger aufbleiben auf den
flächen
[Musik]
so jetzt mehr ein flecken mehr kann man
die einstellungen auf seite tun
jetzt sind wir mit dem ersten
arbeitsvorrat fertig stellen wir die ab
jetzt kommt das nächste gerät also
hiermit sagen jetzt dass die chemikalien
weg also es kommt vor dass klare wasser
und dann sagt man beides ab sozusagen
das tier muss man gleich drauf drücken
ja und dann wird das dann alles klar
[Musik]
so ein graffiti die fassade um die
glaskunst und fertig gemacht
wir mussten werden und die teppiche noch
angucken fleckers weg da passiert wie
neu aus das sehr schön immer gefällt mir
sehr gut
fast schon freut mich also wir haben wir
jetzt die ganze position angeguckt
position als graffiti entferner position
zwei fassadenreinigung haben wir ja auch
kontrolliert glasreinigung hamas
kontrolliert den bischof von johanna es
auch kontrolliert brauche ich noch ein
paar dennoch eine auto dran finden dank
mussten wir nach einer
terminvereinbarung gegen die
glasreinigung ja ich denke vierzehnter
achter also montag so das wird schon
werden
kein problem halten wir fest fällt mir
so fest
bis 14
als
sie hat noch sicherheit wie steiger
arbeiten muss ich mal ein schnell bei
kundl muss ich mal sicherheitsgurt
eintragen schnell weiter arbeiten muss
immer einer unten immer festhalten damit
diejenigen nicht umgibt den mann mit
schnee arbeitet muss man aufpassen dass
man die dosierung wichtig hat dass die
böden nicht kaputt gehen und auch seine
eigene sicherheit das heißt man muss
handschuhe tragen und eine brille
sie wissen gut sein im umgang mit kunden
dass manche objekte sind halt auch dass
die kunden vor ort sind sie müssen
freundlich sein
sie müssen auf den kunden eingehen
können sie müssen wenn der kunde
irgendein problem zu ihnen kommt eine
lösung haben sollten sie haben aber
dafür sind wir dann halt eben darum dass
auch beizubringen das schönste als
gebäudereiniger ist dass man viel um
kommt dass man viele nette
arbeitskollegen hat und dass man immer
was lernt was man noch nicht wusste also
der job ist nicht monoton habe ich gerne
ausbildungen machen sondern habe ich
mich angestrengt gesamten 20 jahren
wir beschäftigen halt mitarbeiter die
keine erfahrung haben in der
gebäudereinigung die werden von uns
anhalt eingewiesen an gelernt dass man
inhalt das optimum mitgeben kann wie
halt noch einigung auszuführen ist bei
uns kann man auch eine ausbildung
starten zum gebäudereiniger
die ausbildung dauert drei jahre und
danach hat man halt irgendwie
möglichkeit als bereichsleiter zum
beispiel oder halt ja selber heute
irgendwelche häuser zu leiten oder
bestenfalls hat auch die menschen sogar
meister zu machen und den weiteren
schritt zur selbstständigkeit ein guter
gebäudereiniger muss schnell und
gründlich arbeiten in meiner job mache
ich das gerne an die macht mir spaß